Everyone knows sequels are never as good as
the originals — except that every once in
awhile, they actually are.
In fact, some sequels turn out to be even
better than the films that preceded them.
These sequels all surpassed the franchise
installments they followed — and some are
now considered classics in their own right.
Spider-Man 2
Sam Raimi's Spider-Man was great, but it was
hampered by two things.
First, it spent a lot of time telling Spider-Man's
origin story before it got around to the main
action.
Second, they made some questionable choices
regarding the villain.
Willem Dafoe was an excellent choice for Norman
Osborn, but his Green Goblin outfit looked
pretty goofy, especially that Power Rangers-style
goblin face.
Spider-Man 2 solved the villain problem by
hiring the spectacular Alfred Molina to play
Doctor Octopus, a villain who doesn't wear
a mask and also has a lot more pathos than
the Green Goblin ever did.
With the origin story already told and such
a fantastic villain to work with, it's no
surprise that this is the best movie in Raimi's
trilogy.
The Empire Strikes Back
Star Wars: A New Hope is an incredibly fun
movie, and it's no wonder it was a world-changing
smash hit.
But the follow-up, The Empire Strikes Back,
manages to retain that sense of fun while
introducing real drama, romance, and tragedy.
A New Hope ends with a big victory, but Empire
is a reminder that wars are long, and even
after a major win you may find yourself on
the run from a stronger opponent, wondering
if winning the battle could still cost you
the war.
In addition to raising the narrative complexity,
Empire also introduces important and interesting
new characters like Lando Calrissian, Yoda,
the Emperor and Boba Fett, who doesn't really
do much other than look cool, but managed
to earn a fan following anyway.
And yes, it has a downer ending, but that
sets up the even bigger triumph of Return
of the Jedi.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
Captain America: The First Avenger was one
long origin story, taking Steve Rogers from
a skinny Brooklyn kid to a World War II super-soldier,
then transplanting him directly to the 21st
century.
Its sequel, Captain America: The Winter Soldier,
took that time-displaced Cap and put him at
the center of a very modern story.
Like many of the character's best comics,
Winter Soldier is all about how Steve Rogers
comes from a simpler time and struggles adjusting
to the complexities of the future.
On top of all that, Winter Soldier makes great
use of the Black Widow, introduces the Falcon,
and even features a fight with Batroc the
Leaper, a long time Marvel villain.
Who, y'know, leaps and stuff.
The Dark Knight
Batman Begins has a lot going for it.
Christian Bale poured a lot of energy into
his dual roles as Batman and Bruce Wayne.
The two villains brought some dark fun some
dark fun to the movie, both representing a
nihilistic worldview that destroys the world
through a misguided desire to purify it.
Then The Dark Knight came along and changed
the whole game, thanks mostly to Heath Ledger's
Joker.
He gives what might be the best Joker performance
of all time, and even though he's incredibly
violent and destructive, he's certainly never
grim.
Despite the ugly makeup, Ledger is magnetic
in every moment he's onscreen.
Such a worthy villain makes this hands-down
the best Christopher Nolan Batman movie, and
one of the best Batman movies of all time.
The Godfather Part II
There are very few examples of a movie and
its sequel both appearing on legitimate lists
of the greatest films of all time, but the
first two Godfather installments frequently
do.
The Godfather was more than just a gangster
film, bringing a level of craft and depth
that the genre had never even approached before.
The Godfather Part II takes that complexity
further, telling a story of family across
two time periods simultaneously.
The Godfather Part II is the continuing story
of Michael Corleone, the previously sheltered
son who has become as great a mafia leader
as his father once was.
But it's also the story of his father in the
past, played here by Robert De Niro, a Sicilian
immigrant in New York City who learns how
things work in his new home, and how much
there is to be gained from a life of crime.
These halves mesh seamlessly into one whole,
a rare achievement in cinema.
The Road Warrior
Mad Max is an interesting, low-budget film
about a cop in a near-future dystopia who
seeks revenge after his family is murdered.
The Road Warrior takes that same character
and builds a whole new world around him.
What was once a collapsing society is now
a full-on post-apocalyptic world.
And while the first movie was about Max's
life, The Road Warrior establishes him as
a wanderer who reluctantly gets involved in
the lives of others.
Add in the now-iconic production design and
costumes, and it's clear that The Road Warrior
is the film that gave George Miller's world
staying power as a classic sci-fi franchise.
Dawn of the Planet of the Apes
In 2011, the Planet of the Apes franchise
was rebooted with Rise of the Planet of the
Apes, a sci-fi drama that focuses on the very
first intelligent ape, Caesar — played through
motion-capture by Andy Serkis — and his
relationship with the human who raised him,
played by James Franco.
It sets the stage for the downfall of humanity
and the rise of the apes, but it doesn't quite
get there.
By Dawn of the Planet of the Apes, set ten
years later, things have progressed, to say
the least.
This is the story of humans who have lost
control of the Earth, and their growing conflict
with the increasingly intelligent apes.
While Rise may have been the key to the way
this saga began, Dawn is where it really gets
exciting.
Star Trek 2: The Wrath of Khan
Bringing Star Trek to the big screen was a
great idea, but even the most diehard Trekkers
will admit that Star Trek: The Motion Picture
was kind of a mess.
The costumes and production design weren't
much to look at, the plot was lifted from
an episode of the TV show, and at a runtime
of more than two hours, the whole thing seemed
to move at a glacial pace rather than warp
speed.
Star Trek II: The Wrath of Khan was where
they figured out how to make a Star Trek movie
work, returning Ricardo Montalban to his role
as the villainous Khan and introducing important
new characters.
Director Nicholas Meyer also brought the whole
thing in at under two hours with plenty of
action and sci-fi awesomeness along the way.
Ask any Star Trek fan what their favorite
movie in the franchise is and they'll usually
only have one answer:
"KHAN!"
Addams Family Values
1991's The Addams Family was a surprisingly
successful adaptation of the classic TV show,
and 1993's Addams Family Values took that
success to even greater heights.
First of all, the sequel takes Wednesday and
Pugsley to summer camp, where their encounters
with more conventionally normal children provide
some of the most memorable gags in either
movie.
Also, most of the first movie is occupied
with a conceit that Uncle Fester is being
impersonated by a con artist, until he turns
out to have been the real Uncle Fester all
along at the end.
In the sequel, we know he's Fester from the
beginning, so Christopher Lloyd can fully
occupy the role in a way he didn't get to
the first time around, and his relationship
with Joan Cusack's black widow, Debbie, is
a particular highlight.
Plus, it brought us this immensely quotable
exchange:
"You...are...Mister Debbie!"
"I am an Addams!"
"Fester!"
X-Men 2
Bryan Singer's first X-Men movie came out
in a time when superhero movies weren't a
sure thing yet, and in retrospect it's hard
not to notice that it hedges its bets, posing
as more of a Matrix-esque sci-fi film.
X-Men 2 is infused with far more confidence.
It makes the X-Men feel more like superheroes,
even if they still wear black leather.
It expands the roles of Iceman and Pyro, introduces
Nightcrawler, and brings the first movie's
major villains, Magneto and Mystique, into
an uneasy alliance with the X-Men against
a much bigger threat.
All of this goes a long way toward building
the kind of complex world and layered character
dynamics that made the comics such a big hit
for so long.
It also just makes a lot more sense than the
first film, foregoing the "deadly device at
the top of the Statue of Liberty" silliness
for a more believable threat of mutant extermination
at the hands of bigotry.
Back to the Future 2
Back to the Future is a fun movie about a
teen from the '80s visiting his teenaged parents
in the '50s.
But Back to the Future Part 2 actually tells
a complex sci-fi story about the nature of
time travel that the first movie didn't even
attempt.
"Roads?
Where we're going, we don't need roads."
In the second movie, Marty goes to the future,
then returns to the present — only to find
that it's been altered because of their actions.
That means he has to go back to the past again
to set things right.
That third segment features scenes from the
original film from different angles, as Marty
does his best to make sure the plot of the
first movie happens as it was meant to.
It's a wild ride.
"Talk about deja vu."
Terminator 2: Judgment Day
The seven years between 1984's The Terminator
and 1991's Terminator 2: Judgment Day marked
a huge evolution in special effects, and an
increased budget made utilizing those state-of-the-art
bells and whistles possible.
In The Terminator, the antagonist is a robot
in human form who's come from the future to
kill Sarah Connor before she gives birth to
a son.
In Judgment Day, that robot has been reprogrammed
to protect Sarah and her son from a more dangerous
model of Terminator.
But the T-1000 isn't just a robot in human
form, it's a shapeshifting killer made of
liquid metal that can take the form of anyone.
The development of CGI "morphing" technology
made the T-1000 possible, and it was mind-blowing
at the time — and even holds up as pretty
impressive today.
Add in an amazing, engaging plot, and this
sequel outmatches its predecessor.
Blade II
The biggest reason Blade II is much better
than the first Blade is simple: Guillermo
del Toro.
The Mexican director was still mostly unknown
in the U.S. when he was hired to direct the
second film based on the Marvel Comics vampire
hunter.
The story of the sequel is pretty similar
to that of the first movie, but del Toro brings
a level of style that really makes Blade II
something special.
The complex fight scenes, Blade's reluctant
vampire allies, and the super-vampires known
as Reapers, are by far the best in any of
the three Blade movies.
Evil Dead 2
Evil Dead is a ridiculous film by accident.
Thanks to a low budget and the off-kilter
sensibilities of director Sam Raimi and star
Bruce Campbell, it turns out to be something
much weirder than your average horror movie.
In Evil Dead 2, Raimi embraced that weirdness
and made full use of Bruce Campbell's comedic
abilities to make a delightfully bizarre horror
comedy that starts in the same cabin in rural
1980s America and ends in medieval Europe.
Everything that came after — Army of Darkness,
Ash vs. Evil Dead, the darker Evil Dead remake
— all happened because of the slick, tongue-in-cheek
self-awareness of Evil Dead 2 far more than
the low-budget original Evil Dead.
After all, Ash isn't really Ash until he replaces
his severed hand with a chainsaw, and this
is the film where that happens.
"Groovy."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!